people may know or may not know but
Futurama has lots and lots of
mathematical secrets embedded in various
episodes my favourite bit of Futurama
maths concerns a particular number and
it crops up everywhere for example if
you look at the whole registry number of
the Nimbus spaceship it is 1 7 to 9 the
registry number has to be something so
what's wrong with 1 7 to 9 what there's
something all about 179 because if you
look at Bender's serial number in the
episode a Christmas story his serial
number is 1 7 2 9 there's another
episode called the Farnsworth Peres box
I think we're fries popping out of
different boxes representing different
universes and one of the boxes he pops
out of his universe number 1 7 2 9 so
someone in Futurama is obsessed with 1 7
to 9 the person who's obsessed is a chap
called Ken Keeler or doctor Ken Keeler
because he has a PhD in applied math he
went to Harvard he worked at AT&T Bell
Laboratories he's published papers in
discrete mathematics he's a heavyweight
mathematician and he's a comedy writer
and he works on Futurama the reason he
loves one 7:29 is he's paying tribute to
a great indian mathematician called
Ramanujan and I know you you've talked
about Ramanujan on on other clips but
just briefly I'll tell you the story
heroic mathematician from very
impoverished background really had very
little formal education but was a genius
of a mathematician but had nobody who
could mentor him so he wrote to lots of
great mathematicians overseas one day a
letter arrived at the the desk of gh
Hardy the great Cambridge mathematician
and hardly looked at this envelope full
of theorems and - either this is
completely fabricated
or it's complete genius and it was the
latter and hardly immediately invited
Ramanujan to sail over to England and
join him at Trinity College Cambridge
Hardy was no sledge Hardy is basically
credited with reinvigorating the whole
of British mathematics which was in the
doldrums at the time but Hardy himself
said you know if I did one truly
thing it was to enable Ramanujan to
flourish and so Ramona turns in England
and and he's doing very well
intellectually but he's suffering
physically he doesn't like the diet here
he's a vegetarian the weather disagrees
with him and the next thing we know
within a few years he's in hospital
really quite seriously ill in Putney and
hardly visits him in hospital and as the
story goes Hardy gets out his cab sits
by Ramanujan spared being mathematicians
they don't necessarily have the most
gossipy chitchat and Ramanujan says well
what was the number of the cab you
arrived it and Hardy says oh it wasn't
very interesting it was 170 to 9 now I
find interesting the fact that he could
remember the number of a cab but that's
another story he says oh it wasn't a
very interesting number
Andrew margin says no no quite the
opposite 179 is a very interesting
number
because it is the smallest number that
is the sum of two cubes in two different
ways one seven two nine and equals 10
cubed plus nine cubed and it also equals
twelve cubed plus one cubed it's rare
for numbers to be the sum of two cubes
in two different ways and this is the
smallest such number so it's a special
number and and Ramanujan you know just
had an extraordinary ability the numbers
to be able to spot these patterns out of
thin air and and for this reason one 729
is called a taxi cab number and that's
why Keeler embeds it in Futurama as a
way of paying tribute to Ramanujan who
died I think about six months later he
went back to India still in poor health
and died at a very young age he just
seems to have dreamt numbers and
imagined numbers and fought about
numbers continually he did tell the
story that at night one of the goddesses
one of the Hindu goddesses would whisper
mathematical secrets into his mind so
whether it was an immense capacity to do
mental gymnastics on the spot or whether
it was just part of his knowledge of
math I guess we don't know you know
people who are watching this may know
that Ramanujan because people watching
this may be very fond of mathematics but
beyond the
little group we're in people have never
heard of Ramanujan and yet thanks to Ken
Keeler and thanks to Futurama there's a
little bit of Ramanujan legacy gets drip
fed on to primetime TV around the world
and in fact Quiles gone one step better
because there's one episode
I think it's benders Big Score where fry
jumps into a taxicab and the number on
the taxi cab is the next rightist an
eight seven or a seven million five
hundred thirty nine thousand three
hundred and nineteen okay that's a
taxicab number in a literal sense it is
the number of the taxicab but it's also
a taxicab number in the ram anujan sense
because it is the smallest number that
is the sum of two cubes in three
different ways so it equals 167 cubed
plus four three six cubed it's also
equal to 2 - 8 cubed plus four - three
cubes and it's also equal to two five
five cubed plus four one four cubed so
we can call that a taxicab number of
rank three it works back to call it with
a very very bad pun and and you might
want to go away and think about what is
the taxicab number of rank four as far
as I know it's never appeared in
Futurama but it may well do one day so
it'll be a way of spotting it so I mean
you kind of alluded to the fact that by
doing this the writer has raised an
awareness to a possibly different
audience about ram anujan do you think
that I mean has he raised awareness is
is it is it a hidden nod to eating I
mean I think if you've never heard of
Ram illusion and you you know into
mathematics
these numbers are arbitrary and and you
won't you won't you won't pick up on it
but I still think it's a tribute I think
it's very personal tribute from from
Kela it's all same just having a bit of
fun it's an in-joke
I think Futurama viewers are probably a
quite a hot a surprisingly high
proportion of them will be interested in
mathematics and will pick up on that
reference I remember one of the writers
said that there was occasionally a bit
of a dispute over mathematics in
Futurama there's a line where there's a
holographic image involving and I think
kif says are a million lies at basic
there and they were sat around the table
in the writers room and they said okay
who knows about basic you know our view
is never going to get that joke and one
of the lead writers at the time said it
just doesn't matter if they don't get it
they don't get it but those people who
know about math you know about computer
science you know about some of the
languages of computer science they'll
get it and it'll be a bit of fun for
them do you ever do it yourself
do you ever drop things into the things
you produce with hidden things that
aren't obvious to your viewers or
readers or is that not the style of a
journalist no no um there are some
references in my latest book which those
who know them will spot them and those
who don't
won't um and those who don't won't have
their fun spoiled but there are
references to a certain legal case that
people may spot and there we go this
video has been brought to you by
audible.com and their huge range of
books that you can download you can
actually get one for free by going to
audible.com/veritasium what one are you
going to download well if you've not yet
got a hard copy version of Simon's book
The Simpsons and their mathematical
secrets maybe you want an audio version
maybe you want to listen to it
hands-free can't be bothered actually
holding it you can download that maybe
that could be your free one audible.com
slash numberphile and thanks to them for
supporting us some good Christmas
reading or listening that one very geeky